I'm wondering because because this  energy remind me of so much of your your  you know the earlier classics and stuff  like that and we're living through such  an age of you know remakes and reduce  I'm wondering what you think the first  Jim Carrey classic movie to be remade  will be my gosh well they have they've  had made many sequels done without me I  wasn't into it  I don't know gosh I don't know I mean I  think Truman Show is is a is is  something that exists on a micro level  now you know it was that it was kind of  a story about that on a macro level but  now everybody has a subscriber channel  you know and everybody has their own  little Truman Show world you know so  there's something to be had there I I  often think and I'm asked about like  what what I think would have happened to  Truman when he goes outside the wall and  and it took me a while to realize that  basically he was alone out there too  because everybody went in back inside  they all wanted to be in the dome